[Music]
so knowing I have a lot of young fans
this may not resonate it but for all of
you hold their peace like me that are
lucky enough to have two children ah
something interesting happened the other
day we have some great friends over Erin
and Francois they preach ildren and erin
was getting their little child ready and
their third child I think on the ground
do like flailing in the air and I was
thinking about how Lizzy and I are
handling Xander compared to Misha and I
realized my god like I asked Baroness
and Erin would you ever let Sebastian
lay like that and she's like absolutely
not and you start realizing it a very
common joke around people that have
young children is how differently you
act the second child or the third child
and the first first one micromanage
having everything video think it's first
part it's six day 6j and believe me
because after the first time it never
seen these on a Tuesday I mean
everything is focused on everything is
micromanage everything is over thought I
have been paying attention to a lot of
people fundamentally and from corporate
America that one every little ROI type
to entrepreneurs that have never been
through it before Gus or a micromanaging
some [ __ ] that actually doesn't matter
it's very obvious to me that the best
piece of advice I could give up in this
moment in this world that where I want
to fill out more content you see it
because I haven't been doing these
videos is freaking business like a
second child
nothing is perfect nothing in business
is black and white all the magic is in
the gray have patience nothing is the
worst thing that ever happened and
nothing is the best thing that ever
happened celebrating when you raise
money is just the beginning
being devastating thinking it's over
when you lost the deal is about the true
reality it's always somewhere in the
middle and if you understand how to
second child to realize the differences
of cool it's eating dirt over there
little Timmy's eating dirt and that's
okay that you would have never let big
sister Janet do that that's the same way
I think you look at your business
nothing is the end of the world nothing
is the greatest thing of all time
embracing the chaos embracing the
nimbleness embracing the things that you
can't control is the complete definition
of a leader that is going to be able to
navigate through the chaotic never
predictable business world so relax grab
a coffee take a shot of vodka it's all
going to be okay your business
[Music]